hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 13 of
book 2 of epic teases discourses we find
him engaged in a very interesting
discussion that seems to center around
what we translate as anxiety the Greek
term for it is I wanna yeah where'd we
get agony from but it also concerns some
other matters as well that are closely
connected including expertise and how we
can rely upon that and how far it can
take us so let's talk first about
anxiety itself and I want to say
something really important from the
start which is that oftentimes if we use
the term anxiety in the 21st century
context a lot of people will think
automatically ok anxiety something
different than fear because it's
existentialism has taught us that or
psychology has taught us that usually
influenced by existentialism and anxiety
is supposed to be this broader state
that doesn't really have any particular
thing that it's afraid of it just has a
general compartment and fears are always
very specific Epictetus doesn't handle
that baggage
built into that and it's not going to be
particularly helpful to import those
ideas in there you can say that I won
the NRA anxiety it is indeed a gentle
state that a person feels but it's not
something that doesn't have any
particular object in fact does have
particular objects that's part of why it
takes the form it does now we can say
that it's not a good state as a matter
of fact it's actually a bad condition
for a person to be in from the stoic
perspective because you don't want to
live a life full of anxiety you want to
live an untroubled existence that's the
goal and so you know it's insofar as you
are feeling anxiety things are not where
they need to be and so far as other
people are feeling anxieties about
things they're not going to be good guy
to post for us that he's going to tell
us in this this chapter
so the key portions then are why do we
feel anxiety what what causes us to feel
anxiety to human beings and then how can
we avoid it because it is something that
the Stoics would say is to be chosen
against right it is something that it
does make sense for us to have an
aversion towards anxiety itself is a
kind of being a burst of things fearing
them but we want to bring to bear a kind
of aversion on that and to desire the
state of untroubled Nisour tranquility
that is indeed possible for us so why do
we feel anxiety
Epictetus says that it stems from a kind
of ignorance that it's not just an
ignorant of particulars it's ignorance
about important things so for example
he'll say that if we're anxious about
how our performance is going to turn out
because we're caring about what the
crowd things we were we're feeling that
and we're thinking that in part because
we don't really understand the nature of
crowds and how mercurial they are and
the fact that they're their opinion
doesn't really count for much in the
grand scheme of things
and actually doing that knowledge but
it's not active and usable at the time
that we're doing it so we feel anxiety
we give the ignorance of all sorts of
things the nature of the genuine good
for ourselves how reliable things are
and so these can cause us to feel
anxiety and anxiety takes the form that
Epictetus is very clear about this of
feeling fear of feeling a sense of here
about things that bad things are going
to happen to us or that good things that
we already possess that we think are
good are going to be taken away it's a
consciousness of our vulnerability not
not necessarily the fact that we are
going to get hurt
or we are going to lose something but
the possibility of that for us and so
anxiety is really a complex of effect
and cognitions at the same time that are
all fused together everyone this is the
way the Stoics in India regard emotions
and emotional responses so he brings it
back to this distinction as he's going
to over and over again and it works what
is in our power what is not in our power
the things that are in our power we
actually have control over and those are
the things that fall within the scope of
our Faculty of choice our moral purpose
that's where our genuine good and our
genuine man lives the things that are
water the things that are not in our
power we don't have control over them
they are not actually good or evil for
us although we will often get mixed up
with things that day they are so what
can we make of this well we don't have
to be anxious about what's in our power
and here's an interesting thing to think
about why don't we have to be anxious
about what's in our power
well because it's in our power we
actually have control over now Saint
meant to some people who aren't very
sure themselves or who come to realize
just how messed up their their habits
and their
oceans and their thoughts about things
really are which can be you know step of
progress right people like that can say
man I don't know if I'm going to be up
to dealing with this that's in front of
me I'm worried about how I'm going to
react for example you know when you go
into a situation going into a
conversation for example that you can't
avoid where you know that the other
person is going to be a real pain and
try to push your buttons and you think
yourself no I'm not sure if I'm going to
be able to handle this or if I'm going
to blow up at them and lose my temper
and say something I'll regret later I'll
give in to the impulse of anger right
Epictetus would say you don't actually
have to be anxious about that because it
really does live within your power
insofar as you are anxious about that
there's probably something else going on
that you want to take a close look at
perhaps you're still allowing some
considerations from the outside to
intrude that you don't really have
control over or perhaps you're
misunderstanding just how much control
you know not total control of course but
the measure of control that you do have
over your own responses so we don't need
to be anxious about the things that we
actually have control over we can you
might say trust ourselves it's a very
liberating message we also shouldn't be
anxious about the things that don't live
within our power
why not because we don't have control
over them you know and I said well that
doesn't really answer things because
doesn't that mean I have to be even more
afraid that other people are going to
screw me over or bad things are going to
happen to be a random or whatever plans
I make are gonna fall through or
whatever desires a hammer or not gonna
be realized and Epictetus says well yes
if you are a designer if you're letting
your desires go scurry around in the
world and latch on to whatever sort of
thing you think is out there that's
going to make you happy you're probably
going to be unhappy and bad things with
there are these bad things in your
viewpoint are going to happen to you
they're not actually bad things in
themselves remember he says that it's
not the things themselves were the
events themselves
it's our viewpoint on them that is that
makes them good or bad so if we allow
ourselves to be fearful about things
that are not in our power we're actually
kind of messing ourselves up and we
really shouldn't do them we have a
choice about whether we feel anxiety now
he's got this really fascinating
discussion that he comes back to several
times in the course of this chapter
about what skill or expertise does for
us and he talks about this in several
other places as well
he actually begins the chapter with us
he says when I see a man and things I
need to ask him I say to myself what can
it be that this fellow wants right we'll
come back to them for if he did not want
something that was outside of his
control how could he still remain an
anxiety this is why the musician
literally the kids are old you know but
who has kids roads East it's like a
guitar player right some guitar player
gets up and he's going to do a
performance or a piano player or what
have you
right so the musician when when doing
their their work all alone they don't
have any anxiety when they're when
they're practicing when they are you
know getting ready for the performance
and the crowd hasn't come in yet they're
not feeling anxious yet but when he
enters the theater even though he has a
very beautiful voice and plays the
instrument admirably he becomes anxious
why what's provoking this anxiety well
Apicius tells us that the skill allows
us to have a reliable expectation that
we're going to perform okay we're going
to perform according to the the you know
standard islam of whatever it is that
we've learned so you know if we're
engaged in some sort of athletic
competition
we've done all of our drills we can
count on our body to do what we want
music is a lot of repetition and
practice
Epictetus a actually says at another
point you know go to a music lesson
really really boring stuff but very
necessary if you want to learn how to
play music well similarly for for public
speaking
similarly for lecturing in front of a
class right you have to learn your topic
and then you have to think about how
you're going to speak about it well and
all those sorts of things the subject
matter expert the the person who has a
skill or an expertise can expect the
third of their you know all things being
equal they're gonna perform well what
they don't control over is how other
people are going to take that
performance how them other people are
going to react and insofar as are being
anxious they're concerned about how the
other people are viewing them which is
very unpredictable you can do a great
performance and people can still boo you
and you know right nasty things about
you and their reviews you know look at
YouTube you know you can do a video
that's great and people this sucks this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
work you know sometimes I get why is he
wearing that tie you know maybe he
should cut his ear and if you take those
sorts of things to heart
you know you're gonna have a very rough
time I often give students this advice
when they are beginning their work
academic writers I say get used to
rejection letters because you're going
to see a lot of them as you send your
work out and quite often the people who
are giving you the rejection letters are
actually making snap judgments you know
a dirty little secret about peer review
is that many times it's not actually
blind and quite often it's not really
review and sometimes an editor will say
we got too many papers find some reason
to you know send this one away
you know reviewers wait until the last
minute before they write their their
reviews and their hasty some reviewers
are just
and you know don't like anybody else
doing well you know this is the sort of
thing that I tell students in part
because I know that they have the chops
to etch the credit paper but I don't
know whether they have the fortitude to
stick it out through having people you
know punching you right we're ready
where it counts not family jewels but
rather in your heart saying your work is
no good right so that's the sort of
thing that makes people even experts
quite anxious and Epictetus redirects
things by saying you actually understand
what the meaning of the crowd is they
don't know anything they don't know any
more than you do so why do you care
about therapy
keep question here's what is being
incorrectly assumed as goods or evils
what does the person makes up about
whenever we feel anxiety that's what's
going on were mixed up about something
so he says for example do I here to
please you what are what I gave thereby
for do you know the standards according
to which man has judged my man have you
been concerned to know what a good man
is and what an evil man and how each
becomes what he is why then are you
announ a good man yourself how do you
make out the answers that I'm not a good
man well no good man grieves or groans
no good man laments no good man trans
people or tremble trembles or asks how
will he receive me how will he listen to
me and Epictetus says the other guy is
going to receive you or listen to you
and seems best to him not necessarily
according to the standards of your
performance it's going to depend how
they feel that day or what other things
are going on in their life or whether
they like you already or dislike you
already or whether they read a review
that says that they should applaud you
or read a review that that says the
opposite so it's not something that you
should be particularly concerned about
and here's the other thing that he point
it says is it possible for one man to
make the mistake and for another to
suffer the harm no why then are you
anxious over what is not your own if you
are anxious over things that another
person controls or that is you know just
a matter of lying causality or random
events happening the way that they do
you are making a mistake
Epictetus would say so anxiety is always
stemming from some sort of error or some
ignorance about the way things really
are and then it leads to fears that we
feel which can then paralyze us which
then can lead us into lines of reasoning
that are not particularly good for us
and keep us from realizing our genuine
good